[Musique]
des mères de l'Ouest parisien avec
Nicolas dandry
et de recevoir ailleurs président de
l'Assemblée nationale merci d'être là
parce que vous avez une journée assez
compliquée hier on va en parler dans
quelques instants vous êtes sans doute
le premier président de l'Assemblée
nationale à venir à l'université des
maires de l'Ouest parisien c'est
d'ailleurs la présidente et l'illus des
Yvelines qui est là oui tout à fait je
viens chaque année à l'université des
mers des Yvelines c'est bien normal je
suis élue de ce territoire de la
cinquième circonscription des Yvelines
j'ai 5 villes dans ma circonscription
dont ça retrouve ville et le président
des maires des Yvelines et le maire de
Sartrouville et puis je suis élue
municipale au Vésinet qui est dans ma
circonscription je siège au conseil
municipal donc c'est tout naturellement
que je suis présente aujourd'hui à cet
université des mers et effectivement
double casquette si j'ose dire des
triples députés concernent municipale et
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale il
n'est pas la moindre des trois
casquettes juste justement quels sont
les relations enfin entre l'Assemblée
nationale et les collectivités
territoriales
vous savez nous sommes tous des élus
nous sommes tous des personnes qui avons
décidé de nous engager au service de
l'intérêt général et au service de nos
concitoyens et cela a différents niveaux
et le premier niveau le niveau de
proximité le niveau de la vie
quotidienne c'est le niveau municipal ce
sont les mers et ses conseillers qui
s'occupent de notre vivre ensemble au
jour le jour donc c'est un échelon
essentiel c'est celui qui fait que nous
arrivons à être dans une société apaisée
et il est important que tous les élus
finalement quel que soit leur niveau de
responsabilité et leur chambre
compétences soit dans cette engagement
collectif pour travailler dans l'intérêt
général et donc travailler toujours main
dans la main quel que soit les couleurs
politiques et c'est ce que nous faisons
dans la dans ma circonscription et dans
les Yvelines d'une façon générale
depuis le vote de la loi sur le non
cumule du mandat il y a parfois des
critiques sur les députés ils sont hors
sol etc et on voit un certain nombre de
projets dont celui d'un député des
Yvelines car le livre qui voudrait
revenir sur ce
non-cumuler peut-être votre position
personnelle est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est un débat qui mérite d'être relancé
en fait il y a plusieurs débats dans
dans celui-là vous avez dit certains
pensent que les élus nationaux sont
hors-sol
oui mais est-ce que c'est vrai moi je ne
le crois pas moi je crois que les élus
nationaux sont des élus finalement comme
les autres sont ont des permanences
rencontrent les citoyens rencontrent
leur mère rencontre des entreprises ils
ont leur vie aussi leur vie de famille
leur vie personnelle ils ont leur vécu
et donc ils sont parfaitement ancrés sur
les territoires et moi je ne suis pas
convaincu que c'est le fait d'avoir une
fonction autre et supplémentaire qui
permet d'être mieux ancré sur un
territoire l'ancrage territorial
s'effectue de façon différente à mon
sens et la question du cumul pour moi
est une question qui est derrière nous
moi je ne souhaite pas que l'on revienne
là-dessus moi je pense et c'est une
conviction profonde que j'ai quand on
exerce un mandat on doit l'exercer à
100%
pleinement dédié à l'exercice du mandat
que les électeurs vous ont confié quand
on est député je pense que il y a
suffisamment de travail suffisamment de
responsabilités sur nos épaules pour
qu'on les exerce à 100% la même façon
pour un maire pour un président de
conseil départemental ou pour un
président de conseil régional je note
une petite différence entre les deux
présidents des assemblées puisque j'ai
interviewé tout à l'heure qui lui et
pour le retour du cumul des mandats
de la vie démocratique nous dans le même
parti nous pouvons avoir des opinions
différentes et au sein de nos deux
assemblées nous pouvons avoir des
opinions différentes l'important c'est
que nous soyons toujours dans une
démarche de dialogue et une démarche
respectueuse et c'est évidemment le cas
avec chacun des interlocuteurs que vous
avez cités
dans les couloirs de l'université des
mairies des Yvelines et des
Hauts-de-Seine par rapport au coût de
l'énergie c'est le principal sujet qui
ressort depuis ce matin aussi sur notre
plateau
l'AMF l'Association des Maires
d'Île-de-France
projette une augmentation entre 30 et
300 % des coûts de l'énergie pour les
communes aujourd'hui comment les maires
peuvent faire face et quel impact vous
vous pouvez avoir au niveau de
l'Assemblée nationale alors la question
de l'énergie effectivement elle
préoccupe les collectivités
territoriales et les maires au premier
chef elle préoccupe aussi les
entreprises et moi je me suis rendue à
plusieurs reprises sur des sur des sites
industriels et on voit que les coûts de
production explosent donc c'est une
problématique que nous devons prendre
globalement et traiter aussi bien pour
les entreprises que pour les
collectivités donc il y a plusieurs
pistes de travail plusieurs propositions
un plafonnement du coup du mégawattheure
un plafonnement global de l'augmentation
un bouclier tarifaire qui serait adapté
aux entreprises et aux collectivités une
chose certaine c'est que il faut prendre
en compte ce qui est finalement
aujourd'hui plus qu'une inquiétude c'est
une réalité auquel ces entreprises et
les mères sont confrontées et cela
impacte la vie quotidienne des mairies
et donc notre vie quotidienne et ça
impacte aussi l'avenir à travers
peut-être des reports d'investissement
qui ne seraient pas bons donc nous
devons agir pour les protéger comme nous
avons d'ores et déjà protégé nos
concitoyens et donc il y a plusieurs
pistes à l'étude mais cette inquiétude
nous l'entendons et nous devons nous
devons y répondre on l'a vu cet été vous
avez déjà voté des enveloppes dans un
dans un projet de loi dans une loi
rectificative de finances
vous avez aidé des communes alors il y
avait un seuil quand même parce que
toutes les communes n'ont pas pu être
aidé parce que finalement il y a des
conditions tout à fait mais aujourd'hui
80% des communes sont aidées pour en ce
qui concerne les prix de l'énergie ce
sont en fait toutes les plus petites
communes qui ont peu d'employés
communaux et qui arrivent à rentrer dans
les dans le dans le système que l'on a
que l'on a voté maintenant la question
se pose pour les communes de taille plus
importante pour lesquelles il faut avoir
des dispositifs adaptés
du meilleur concertation avec les
collectivités territoriales une
meilleure confiance une plus grande
confiance elle a pas prononcé le mode de
décentralisation est-ce que vous seriez
pour un nouvel acte de décentralisation
et ne vous aura pas échappé que le
Président de la République oui
moi je pense que nous devons aborder ces
questions de façon très pragmatique et
sans tabou finalement et de regarder
quels sont les bons échelons pour
prendre les bonnes décisions et surtout
évitez tous les doublons éviter
que les uns et les autres finalement
marchent sur les plates bandes du voisin
je pense qu'il faut beaucoup de clarté
parce que nos concitoyens n'y
comprennent plus grand chose donc qui
fait quoi et quand donc je pense que si
nous allons vers un nouvel acte de
décentralisation il devra nécessairement
s'accompagner d'une simplification et
d'une clarification moi je n'y suis je
n'y suis pas opposé je pense que ces
questions institutionnelles doivent se
regarder globalement c'est ce que le
président de la République avait annoncé
pendant sa campagne présidentielle à
travers une commission transpartisane
pour examiner l'ensemble des questions
institutionnelles et dans les questions
institutionnelles il a il y a évidemment
la question des territoires des
compétences et de cette éventuellement
nouvelle acte de décentralisation
justement par rapport à ce propos
l'autre inquiétude et l'autre terme
qu'on entend et l'expression qu'on
entend beaucoup sur l'université des de
l'Ouest parisien c'est le terme
d'autonomie financière des collectivités
locales vous parlez décentralisation
c'est le transfert des compétences mais
à côté faut des moyens aujourd'hui dans
le projet de loi de finance vous
souhaitez supprimer la CVAE la
contribution des entreprises aux
collectivités territoriales est-ce que
justement ça va pas contre sens du
vouloir plus de décentralisation mais en
même temps récupérer plus de fiscalité
de pouvoir fiscal des collectivités
l'idée à travers la suppression de la
CVAE c'est vraiment de continuer à
baisser les impôts tels que l'on l'a
fait sur une trajectoire de puis cinq
ans l'idée c'est de ne pas
que les que les mères et que les
collectivités territoriales n'ont
participent pas et donc le dispositif
qui va remplacer la CVAE déjà la CVAE va
être supprimée de façon progressive ça
ne va pas se faire d'un coup et surtout
le dispositif et là ça s'est créé en
lien justement avec les collectivités
sera un dispositif de remplacement
dynamique parce que on ne peut pas
justement traiter les collectivités de
la même façon selon qu'elles ont un
dynamisme économique sur leur territoire
ou pas et donc l'idée c'est d'avoir
justement cette cette remplacement
dynamique et donc je pense que ce
faisant on répond à leur inquiétude de
pouvoir parce que les collectivités
finalement n'ont plus de pouvoir de
fixer un taux d'imposition un taux de
contribution au sein des conseillers
municipaux départementaux ou régionaux
moi j'ai pas le sentiment que ce soit
une perte de pouvoir ce qui est
important c'est que elle est surtout
elle continue à bénéficier de leur
financement et que ces financements
puissent évoluer que ce ne soit pas figé
dans le temps alors on va parler un peu
de la sauvé nationale que vous présidez
vous êtes la première période d'une
assemblée qui n'a pas la première
présidente de l'Assemblée n'a pas une
majorité absolue oui vous êtes la
première femme non je veux dire c'est
pas la première fois que le président a
une assemblée qui n'a pas une majorité
absolue mais enfin c'est quelque chose
qui compte tout de même comparer un peu
les députés à des fromages j'ai vu il y
a les moules et dures non c'était pas
vrai ça si mais c'était
non non non mais attendez c'est avec
nous mais c'est surtout que j'ai
souhaité faire un cocktail de fin de
session que nous c'est un cocktail
traditionnel et j'ai voulu mettre à
l'honneur l'ensemble des fromages de nos
territoires ce qui est une façon aussi
de sublimer les ce que de notre pays et
les différences donc effectivement le
discours a j'ai eu quelques métaphores
sur les fromages mais c'était en lien
avec le buffet mais depuis que votre
élection c'est vrai que vous êtes une
présidente qui a pris soin de faire
travailler l'assemblée d'avoir
d'écouter les opus d'être à l'écoute des
oppositions
ça ça a plutôt bon bien fonctionné
jusqu'à présent mais là est-ce qu'avec
le la discussion budgétaire on rentre
pas dans le dur comme dit en berger si
les oppositions ne veulent pas voter à
tout prix on sera forcé elle nous force
à utiliser le 49-3 est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cette analyse il y a
effectivement deux sortes de textes il y
a des textes sur lesquels nous pouvons
bâtir des compromis et j'appelle à ce
que compromis soit bâti si possible en
amont en ayant des concertations très
approfondie et donc ce sont les textes
que nous avons voté cet été c'est le
texte que nous avons voté hier en
première lecture sur l'assurance chômage
et donc ça ça fonctionne et ensuite il y
a voilà mais c'est la création de
consensus de compromis et d'une
discussion et c'est ça une assemblée une
assemblée qui fonctionne de façon pleine
et entière c'est une assemblée qui débat
et qui construit des textes qui semblent
correspondre à ce qui s'est dit pendant
les débats et c'est ce que nous faisons
après il y a le vote du budget et le
vote du budget traditionnellement dans
notre assemblée c'est un signe
très fort d'appartenance ou non à une
majorité pour vous dire le règlement du
groupe la République en marche sous la
précédente mandature prévoyait
l'exclusion d'un député qui voterait
contre le budget parce que voter le
budget ou ne pas le voter c'est c'est
finalement être pour ou contre les eaux
grandes orientations du gouvernement
c'est un acte essentiel et donc le fait
que les oppositions ne souhaitent pas et
les d'ores et déjà annoncé souhaiter le
budget en fait et finalement assez
logique compte tenu du contexte actuel
mais c'est la n'aubère pas les accords
que nous pourrions avoir sur d'autres
textes de fonds où là les débats peuvent
avoir lieu et n'engage pas les
oppositions dans une appartenance ou non
à une majorité j'aimerais revenir sur
deux épisodes dans l'exercice de votre
président à l'Assemblée nationale la
semaine dernière au hors berger pose une
question sur les violences conjugales
elle est euh incessamment coupé par les
députés de la nups et je reviens sur
l'épisode d'hier aussi la question posée
par le député du rassemblement national
au ministre de l'Économie le ministre de
l'économie se fait traiter entre
guillemets de lâche qu'est-ce qui se
passe dans votre esprit à ce moment-là
parce qu'on a vu que vous avez suggéré
c'est ces deux situations avec fermeté
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans votre esprit
quand vous voyez ça en fait
je suis je suis déçu pour trouver de
dire parce que moi je défends chaque
député qui siège dans cette assemblée
parce que chaque député a été élu par
les Français donc et légitime à siéger
dans cette assemblée mais une assemblée
c'est le lieu du débat organisé
respectueux entre les uns et les autres
mais respectueux aussi des personnes qui
vous ont élu et je trouve que lorsque le
débat d'érable lorsque il y a des
invectives envers des députés ou en
verre un ministre ou envers celui qui
exerce la présidence lorsque finalement
l'assemblée n'est plus au lieu de débat
apaisé respectueux mais dans ces cas-là
il faut que je puisse et c'est ce que je
fais sanctionner les parlementaires qui
iraient trop loin et c'est une déception
parce que moi je vois et j'écoute les
Français et les Français me disent qu'il
souhaite que l'assemblée justement dans
laquelle il n'y a pas de majorité
absolue dans laquelle il y a tous les
partis qui sont représentés ils
souhaitent que cette assemblée
fonctionne il souhaite qu'elle délibère
il souhaite qu'elle vote des textes dans
leur intérêt et donc quand l'Assemblée
n'est plus en capacité de le faire je
trouve qu'en fait nous ne remplissons
pas pleinement le mandat que nous ont
confié nos électeurs et c'est pour ça
que je suis déçu
de Street padoison qui avait
xénophobie à propos des débuts national
je suis contente de pouvoir expliquer
cela en fait ça n'est pas tant le mot
parce que le mot finalement est une
description d'un parti politique et
cela peut être démontré à ses aimants
mais j'avais appelé à ce qu'il n'y ait
pas d'invective les uns envers les
autres à ce que les débats reviennent
dans un climat serein et calme et en
fait vous ne pouvez pas avoir des
invectives incessantes et c'est ça que
j'ai sanctionné et à Street Panossian la
parfaitement
moi je donc il y a le fond il y a la
forme il y a le texte il y a le contexte
et nous étions dans un contexte global
où il fallait impérativement faire
retomber la pression et impérativement
que les débats reprennent un cours
beaucoup plus apaisé et c'est ce que
j'ai signifié à Madame Panossian hier
après-midi et elle l'a compris il fait
partie
mais mon rôle n'est pas tout à fait mais
mon rôle n'est pas un rôle partisan
lorsque je préside d'une séance il est
impératif et Gérard Larcher mon
homologue du Sénat me démentira pas
d'être dans la plus parfaite
impartialité tout le monde exigence
c'est une depuis le début de votre
président merci beaucoup juste un mot
juste un mot pardon parce que j'ai lu
que vous étiez un peu agacé quand on
cite les successeurs possibles de
d'Emmanuel Macron clinique des hommes
j'ai lu ça dans le monde
et alors et alors tout le monde dit bah
oui parce qu'elle y pense
il faut pas croire tout ce qu'on lit
mais ça vous le savez parfaitement moi
je ne pense qu'à une chose c'est à faire
réussir cette Assemblée nationale j'ai
l'immense honneur de la présidée je suis
la première femme présidente et ma seule
mission c'est de réussir cette résidence
et faire en sorte que l'Assemblée
nationale retrouve sa place au coeur de
notre vie démocratique et dans le coeur
des Français merci beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]